alright it is 7 o'clock in the morning
and it's time to wake up by taking thing
to school are you dreaming about
anything but they're rubber are you
doing Thanks mmm your night lights
I need to get ready for the morning oh
oh
first get close this there's school
you're a fast waker-upper it takes me
forever to wake up hey we're making your
lunch
[Music]
you guys won hmm what happened you
waiting for that food to come out think
you're scheduled for is 7:30 is that
okay with you we have an automatic
feeder for the cats and it's scheduled
for 7:30 every morning I wake up they
meow at me thinking hey get us some food
thinking like I'm gonna get the food any
sooner
funny
[Music]
anyways it's time to make Isaac some
watch
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
and then I went back here and then my
room is started red lights flash I'll
scared out obviously now is just a
nightmare because every time I have
nightmares and I wake up and I'm like oh
thank goodness it was just a nightmare
this is a dream from last night
yeah it was my dream for less I asked
you you said to have a dream you said
our mother is idea remember a fair time
so I have the dream work there just
please call it Ranger work truck I don't
really remember it's not really a real
place though I just made it up in my
mind but I'm not making it up right now
it was a cementery so in the dream I
went inside Richard's workshop and then
I came back here at the help and then I
went to my room and in my mind I was
thinking wow how did I get you I went up
in my bed one is sleep and there's like
a couple people that went and to guide
me and then they disappeared so they're
kind of like ghost scary with a warning
Newark I like they were cursing you like
your car smell when you render your
workshop they're kind of mourning with
the scary voice and then I heard a knock
on the door I went to open it there is
two people my best friend Kane and my
friend Michael Jackson my friend's name
is Michael so I like to call my cousin
so they walked upstairs I was like just
let you know she's haunted so they said
really
and iron or red lights flash like this
turns red lights it was a scary for me
true that little lights coming from the
ghost because uh it actually goes trying
to haunt us
there's like oh oh that's what happened
next
yep long story short did I save you from
your nightmare cuz I woke you up
oh yeah yeah just you're in my timing
guys like some breakfast breakfast a lot
of cereal can eat all that cereal it's a
small boy
[Music]
boy you're bad luck
Oh brave forget to write this word is
the same thing it happened my dream but
only got house are you sure you're not
dreaming right now nope he comes up for
one item you look forget the other one
where's your lunchbox is your lunchbox
downstairs yeah
[Music]
hi guys hi my baby have a good day at
school guru kiss bye have a good day at
school
love you stay smart Oh hurry the boring
are you doing now go I gotta go get my
hair done whoo Jerry's gonna do some
touch-ups
cuz a lot of the colors fading and then
the roots it didn't turn out as good she
was working on like five other people so
now like she can actually like go [ __ ]
myself you and then try to try to fix
some stuff and I'm also gonna cut my
hair little shorter gonna be higher up
more time in the salon all right time to
water the garden spend time with my
plants I never thought I'd be into
gardening because growing up my mom
would always garden and I always thought
it was like a girl's thing to do or like
a old person thing to do and I never
thought I would find myself in the
position of like enjoying it now that I
have a tomato plant it kind of like
spawned like this desire to want to tend
to plants it's a very zen-like effect
too watering plants for me almost kind
of like a meditation process I came to
him into gardening because I'm not into
gardening I'm just into watering plants
at the moment all right time to get some
editing done about for our ethical pick
up Isaac TIFF is getting her hair done
she's in a reconvene with me before
people pick up Isaac and then as we pick
up Isaac we're gonna go to the office
wherever we're gonna have our work day
started roughly around 3 p.m.
[Music]
sniff his home back from our hair
appointment see what she looks like now
Wow come to light what you think what -
thanks Oh daily good that's like almost
all my I just didn't want to bleach the
very very roots how come you don't want
to bleach it scary cuz I'm like your
hair falls out and creates balls pods
and I just don't want to mess in my
roots I like it it's like way more aw
she added a she had a more blue into it
yeah it's way more vibrant I didn't cut
it because I'm gonna be getting a
blowout soon and then that's when I'm
gonna cut it I like it I'm gonna get
some model shots know what I like your
sandals - I'm not a model I can't love
ya you become a model once we go into
slow motion okay we're going to slow
motion right now first I gotta pee
[Music]
all right good all right so we now have
this boy back hola
did you tell your friends about your
nightmare happy face all right Wow
that's it Wow all right so now that we
have babe Isaac we're gonna have some
lunch I'm hungry I know we're gonna eat
now cereal wore off like real fast
well I mean it is like lunchtime now
that's true it's past it's like almost 3
o clock now let's go you have yellow one
then we switch to white it's white
that's why right now oh you want the
yellow cheese
you got there
strawberry game wait hold on it's like a
strawberry jam for grilled cheese huh
what does it taste like these
strawberries
does it taste kind of cheesy ish yeah
it's a brilliant strawberryish honey
so when Isaac was little rusev oh yeah
all the time
all three of us one day he ordered a
protein sandwich and you know and I hope
that like the tray of Siragusa
he picks out strawberry syrup he's like
one week in a heavy one with protein
I think it was like three or four like
strawberry syrup with croce that's so
good I'm like okay you like that let's
try it I'm thinking in my head I'm like
gonna hate it
I like this well look here's
don't do it I feel like Isaac you're
onto something because putting Jam with
grilled cheese now which is a kind of
food item that you would find in those
food trucks like those really trendy
like new food places I feel like you're
inventing something here the game so how
you do it oh you just put it right on
the part of your gonna bite I was
strawberry right you like strawberry
fries to try it
that's good nice I think you gonna be a
chef one day one of you chef one day
chef that's the cutest food yeah no
that's like lunch dinner and breakfast
all then you look like you're carrying
something illegal in that bag and got a
pistol on your hip like I can't hurt
anybody
kind of merchandise a cherry in there
more guns
actually does have more fitting really
good is there you're an arms dealer here
our killer that needs to protect your
your merchandise with another guns
[Music]
[Music]
Neela's kid she's chillin living a life
no worries
homeworks done what a sweet life